mensch dich hier in cala millor genau am
strand video schon gesagt das ist es
leer es gibt ein paar spaziergänger denn
man darf wieder sport machen und man
darf auch wieder spazieren gehen aber
wann ist jetzt letztendlich ein mehr
saison geben kann und wie die vielleicht
aussehen soll ist zurzeit noch unklar
haben die hotelbetreiber haben die
gastronomen diese saison schon
abgeschrieben oder hoffen sie dass da
noch was geht auf mallorca naja sie
hoffen natürlich alle doch auf eine
saison wenn auch eine späte saison
es haben derzeit schon seit dem 11 seit
dem ersten mai entschuldigung ein paar
hotels geöffnet zurzeit gibt es drei
hotels auf mallorca am wochenende soll
noch ein viertes hotel dazu kommen
allerdings sind die erstmal nur für
geschäftsleute eröffnet worden